Richard justice of mlb.com and a man who
has been covering this sport for decades
joins us here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Richard
I'm good rich how are you today did I I
mean is that a fair assessment of the
Marlins situation Richard the fair
assessment is these fans have been put
through too much they've been put
through too many reconstructions bill
hope tear down bill hopes hair down and
you're right they did it contributed to
building a ballpark on the other hand
you know the franchise had to have the
ballpark here's what Derek Jeter has to
do rich he has to come in and give them
some credibility I I'm okay with this
plan I'm okay with trading all these
guys and breaking people's hearts again
an accumulating talent I'm just saying
this time you have to stay the course
you can't have a change in ownership you
can't have a change in baseball ops
you can't fire the manager every twenty
minutes every time you get upset about
something the credibility is zero in
that market for that franchise and
everyone knows it
that's why baseball you know Scott one
of the things God said we need to do a
better job of vetting the owners
baseball was honored and thrilled to
have Derek Jeter involved because he did
bring credibility but it's going to take
months and years to do it it's not going
to happen overnight and these are tough
tough times when you trade a player like
Giancarlo Stanton and you you've trade
your three or your four best players is
what you've done and you're probably
going to trade the other guy Christian
out Yelich it's bad but you know I lived
through it in Houston I've seen what the
Reds are trying to do what the Brewers
tried to do it is hard it is hard to
watch but what happened in Houston is
because you know the guys who had been
there for so long just got old and they
weren't replaced and you know now two of
them are in the Hall of Fame and Biggio
and Bagwell Richard I mean baseball
didn't baseball know that the God that
Jeter would be working for was known as
the paper shredder and the newspaper
business Richard a business that you
obviously know very well did they not
know that the guy who buys it and that's
the problem too
is that if you're selling it if you're
buying a team for 1.2 billion dollars in
a market that has helped build a stadium
to inflate that value
shouldn't the fans expect a 115 million
dollar payroll to be kept at that if not
maybe added to since they have enough
money to buy the team what why must they
sell-off why can't they have 125 135
million dollar payroll and use the guys
that they haven't built around them
right right after Scott Boras said those
things about the Marlins he also tried
to convince the Red Sox you can sign
both Eric Hosmer and JD Martinez it's
only money
yeah I understand what you're saying
they met all the ownership requirements
for baseball in a perfect world you
would like to say okay where to come in
we're going to throw money at we're
going to have a two hundred million
dollar payroll the first year we're
going to because that was a team that
was close
you had pitching to that group and I
think they'd be pretty good
remember that Marlins did that a couple
of years ago didn't work out the
candidates didn't didn't spike up and
they tore it down a few years I would
just say this and I was talking to
Michael Hill the Marlins president
baseball off yesterday mm-hmm
and he said listen Derek Jeter didn't
get into this thing to fail we're going
to succeed and it's going to it's not
going to be pretty at the beginning and
I know people are sick and tired of
hearing that we're going through this
again you're putting us through this
again there has to be a light at the end
of the tunnel I my only point would be I
know Derek Jeter and I trust a guy and
if he says this is the best path to get
out of this do it all right Richard
Justus let's move on here to other items
why is Manny Machado on the trade block
because he's a year away from free
agents this is not a good time to trade
a guy a year away from free agency the
Orioles have exact Britain one of the
best closers in the game a year away and
they had Adam Jones the face of their
franchise and you're away from free
agency oh and by the way the general
manager and manager are in the final
years of their contract you I don't
think they're going to trading
I don't think Peter Angelos would
approve that but what you have to do is
you have to do your in the Razr doing
the same thing with Chris Archer and
other guys if to do your due diligence
and say what it would this be the best
move the best move would be have been to
have a longer view and to trade him at
the all-star break last year or a year
ago decide it is very tough to trade a
guy a year you're out now here's
here's what you could do you could you
could trade them to the White Sox and
the White Sox could flip him to the
Yankees but the Yankees and the Yankees
have a great farm system but they seem
to be engaged on getting a starting
pitcher ie Gerrit Cole at this point so
I think the reason you do it is just to
be able to go back to ownership and say
here are our options on this because he
is going to test the market you know we
know that and and he is mean he's 25
years old rich I mean he's a he's a
great player and the idea that I mean
when you get into the marketplace the
numbers and we all talk about Bryce
Harper but the numbers on Machado are
gonna be pretty spectacular - and that's
puts a franchise in uncertain water yeah
and it all makes Stanton's numbers maybe
even at the end of the day a bargain
well well I think that's one of the
reasons free agency's been held up well
you know what every team tried to get
Otani and then Stanton had to be
resolved so if you're Scott Boras and
you've got Eric Osman JD Martinez you
look at that deal 10 years to 95 that's
what's left on Stanton you go okay
that's where wheel stud is where we'll
start the conversation everything is
connected to every other little thing
Richard justices of mlb.com joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show so what is
the market of the other top free agents
and his Boras control all of it yeah he
does control he controls
I think the top for Hosmer Moustakas JD
Martinez and Jake Arrieta it's it's well
you know we're in the trade phase right
now we're gonna see what the Rays are
doing what the Orioles are doing in
terms of trading their guys and then
we'll get down to business and Scott
Boras I mean the Red Sox want to do a
deal rich they want to do a deal
yesterday for JD Martinez and or Eric
Hosmer
but Scott likes to let the market play
out and you have X factors involved you
know but I mean the Brewers have money
to spend the Twins have money to spend
the Angels the Padres I mean there are
lots of teams that are going to be
engaged in this market and so for you
have a very aggressive general manager
in Boston and Dave Dombrowski but Scott
is just not inclined to do anything
really fast
so I mean let's talk about the Angels
not only just because this show is on
angels radio KLA every single day but
Otani is just such a fascinating story
and fascinating figure what is baseball
looking into about with his elbow
Richard walk through this process here
olá bet now that part simple medical
reports are shows to be confidential
somebody leaked a medical report and if
the Commissioner finds out who it was
it's going to be unpleasant it's going
to be bad because whoa what's the
motivation to leak this and what he has
is something that a ton of pitchers have
in their elbow he's getting these
injections but this was not something
that scared off any team you know any
and then Winter Meetings people were
going okay who would do something like
that you go Texas and I'd say no I know
John Daniels he would not do that you
know we went down the list somebody did
it and you know the Commissioner is
pissed so this is in terms of for the
angels
no no buyer beware no caveat emptor it's
just what a lot of pitchers have and
they they're gonna put them out there
every fifth day and he's gonna rake and
we're gonna see if he really can live up
to thy Richard yeah it's a whole new
world we haven't done this in 99 years
papers last year in boss you know it's
it's it tells you that people debate the
teams are being run by people who are
more open minded about it
willing to look at a world the world a
different way the race to use the fourth
pick in the last in the seventeen draft
on the kid named Brendan McKay from
Louisville this summer he played first
base and pitched de-aged did it find the
Dodger Senate young guy named Brett
Eichner pitched at Arkansas and played
centerfield they sent him back to the
minor leagues okay we're gonna make you
a pitcher and a hitter he he blue had
his elbow in it but when he comes back
they're looking at him is he's a guy
that can take it can save us a roster
spot will it work you know for people
like me who've seen the way Max Scherzer
Justin Verlander work between starts
it's so intense the work it's hard for
me to imagine him going to play first
base or DHE inter play the outfield
after going through a full day's work
you have to be able to look at it and
one thing Otani wanted to hear is mike
scioscia are you willing to give this a
try he wants to do it badly and you know
and I think now we're Scouts rich when
they Scout college guys a lot of these
guys pitch and hit both and they always
had this argument well you know maybe
we're looking at a time where we're
gonna do both because this is a new
general generation of general managers
who are open to things like that Richard
have a great holiday season a new year
we'll chat with you down the line know
when things begin heating up again thank
you rich same to you you bet that's
Richard justice at Richard justice on
Twitter mlb.com for more Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Rich Eisen show app